basically all my friends parents were
like Amy Poehler and Mean Girls my
parents are great now and were so strict
growing up they are both very religious
Catholic believers first of all my dad
is the cleanest man alive his house is a
museum I wasn't even allowed to say
freaking because it sounded like [ __ ] I
realized my parents were strict probably
sometime in elementary school when other
kids got to have sleepovers and I did
not unless they knew the kid's parents I
wasn't allowed to hang out with them
where they were not to come over my mom
would let me stay at other people's
houses but then as they were going to
sleep she would just show up and be like
time to go I wasn't really allowed to go
out after school like until I was like
18 but I would anyway I thought I was
being like super cool and rebellious but
I was like go skateboarding and friends
I would bring over my friends who were
clearly gay men and my parents would
like flip out that I was gonna get
impregnated in the time that we were
playing Wii U every summer my mom would
sit me down and make me learn like half
of my math class for the next year that
went to public school but then at night
I had to go to Catholic school basically
all day I was in school every Friday
night my mom would allow me to go
upstairs to play video game for one hour
exactly and then I would have to go down
do math homework with her and I wouldn't
pray that she would just forget she
never did one rule was you have to be
home by sunset there's a period of time
during the fall where the Sun Goes Down
at 4:00 and then I wasn't out of school
and I had to explain that to my dad and
he was just like when the Sun is down
you are home when I was a kid and I
lived with my father it was a little
tough you know you kick off your shoes
you're watching TV the end of the night
and you forget and you go to bed the
next morning they'll be in the trash you
wouldn't throw them to the trash inside
the house he'd throw them in the trash
outside of the house more times than one
my parents caught me masturbating they
basically just told me to not do it
again like just literally for the rest
of my life to never jack off again my
brother was allowed to do whatever
want he could be out when the Sun was
down he could be in the room with a girl
in our house I feel like my brother if
you asked him would be like there were
no rules I wasn't allowed to date until
I was 16 I started dating at 13 and I
didn't care but I got political for that
my mom was very against dating in
general and so my counter-argument would
be like oh so you want me to die an old
spinster and she'd just be like no I'll
just choose your husband for you one of
the biggest fights me and my dad ever
got in was that I was not allowed to
wear short shorts or short skirts so I
had these pair of leggings that I would
wear out of the house and then as soon
as I got to like school or wherever else
I would take the leggings off but I had
to remember to put the leggings on when
I got home and sometimes I would forget
but I would just like brought upstairs
my room and hope that nobody noticed and
then one time I pierced my ear and I
just came to his house with a pierced
ear he looked like I slapped my
grandmother or something you know I was
Lee's expression like he couldn't
believe it does something like that I
think as I've gotten older my
relationship with my parents has
definitely become more reasonable I
think my parents could have laid back on
the idea that if I got a B on one class
my life would just be over I appreciate
that they sheltered me it gave me
structure to my life and it made me more
responsible and they maybe didn't get
into as much trouble as I would
that makes you appreciate all the stuff
that you earned it feels like you earned
every privilege yeah I get why my
parents were strict and if I had a kid
like me when I was a kid um that's like
my worst fear even though I wish that my
parents were less strict I feel like I'm
gonna be more strict than my parents
mainly I want funny kids I want them to
be vine famous when they're toddlers or
they're useless